you want some tea is there a movie that
you really regret turning down yeah even
Jennifer Lopez has some career regrets
you sign on to be an actress and you
resign yourself to the fact like I'm
gonna go all the way or I'm not gonna
take the role and one of those roles
gets name checked as JLo answers vogue's
73 questions and what is the most
important thing that you do to prepare
for a role
research
just dig into all the details of who the
character is what they do and for JLo
there's one role that got away and by
Got Away we mean she seemingly passed on
the project is there a movie that you
really regret turning down
unfaithful
you want to dance
now yep Jennifer Lopez nearly co-starred
with Richard Gere in one of 2002's
biggest films
so that's what's bothering you
it's bothering me while JLo stopped
short of explaining why she regrets it
we can take a guess
the love affair Thriller earned critical
Acclaim for the star who said yes Diane
Lane she was nominated for a Golden
Globe and an Academy Award
be happy for this moment
this moment is your life
I'm blown away I'm blown away I'm very
thrilled and honored I can't deny it but
JLo also takes a moment to appreciate
her breakout role which of your
characters are you most similar to
um I think there's a little bit of me in
all the characters I play but I would
have to say Selena
as an actress you know one of the great
things about doing things is not just to
do fictional characters but to also
recreate this incredible human life you
know and for me that's why it's such a
it's such a blessing it's an honor to be
able to to do this well even though she
missed out on a big role JLo laner
received all the praise for her
performance in hustlers
there's nothing like it is there and
which of your performance has challenged
you the most
um Ramona the poem
[Music]
let me tell you when we filmed the scene
I was terrified I was so and I I was so
ready for it like I was prepared I was
ready I knew exactly what I was doing
and as I walked to the stage you know in
dental floss literally wearing nothing I
said to myself oh my God what am I doing
with my life right now oh my God and
then after I did it I was like I really
got into the mindset of like I'm gonna
take all your money that's what I'm
gonna do right now it's a it's a mindset
that these girls have
[Music]